dude that house is giving away full-size
candy bars that house forgave my student
loan debt what the hell kind of street
is
[Music]
this I'll give you the rest when you
retire are you a real woman did you get
the student loan thing kind of they said
the house on the right made them stop
using the front door so I had to go to
the back door and I only got 10K because
I don't work in the public SE well the
house on the right gave me an AR-15 holy
crap but they made me burn my library
card something about drag queens that
old guy on the left makes you sit
through Dei training and then takes half
your candy if he thinks you have too
much doesn't that guy own like three
houses yeah and all his candy has
stickers that say it may cause cancer
that guy on the right took away my Mikes
these things are a slippery slope to
Three Musketeers I've seen a ton of
AirHeads and Dum Dums on the far left
there's a huge Horror Show going on on
the right too but those guys are having
trouble with their speaker every new
one's worse than the last that red house
only gives out candy if you pass a drug
test oh wait did you get drugs not good
ones but the one on the far left gave me
hormone blockers what about that yellow
house with the snake flag they're into
drugs right it sounds like they were f
fighting inside you don't belong in this
house it's not your house it's my house
I have the keys took the keys why is no
one giving out drugs the news said we'd
get drugs maybe people enjoy taking
drugs more than they enjoy giving them
to children did you hit that little pink
house somebody did all right just don't
go too far left the rumor is they're
forcing every kid to dump out their bags
so they can redistribute all the candy
equally well that doesn't seem so
terrible they say the same thing every
year and in the end they murder the kids
with too much candy or education and
eventually everyone starves I don't know
why kids keep going there well maybe
this year it'll be different the kids
are always dead by some I bet they just
sent those kids to Camp I mean you're
wrong but you're also not wrong oh yeah
I get it now what's your position on
abortion you can take as many as there
are genders just stick to the middle I
already got a stimulus check sugar
subsidies a sports stadium that house
even gives you cash if you promise not
to grow any corn I heard the Menendez
house had gold bars but they're not
answering the door anymore oh hey it's
that foreign exchange student what's
your hul look like zilinsky 75 billion
but the night is
young 75 billion it's how neighborhoods
compete now it's like a proxy Halloween